okay we're gonna we're gonna see if this
works I gotta test it what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel today
I'm gonna be doing some reactions
um
let me see let me see if this is working
oh yeah I I made the thumbnail today and
I'm not a very good thumbnail editor
um so I apologize for that it's kind of
ugly
um but Chris if you're watching this
please replace the thumbnail because
this is
not just probably Productions level but
it's okay it's okay let me just make
sure this shit's working
um
it's live
is this alive
I don't know I'm I've been struggling
lately with the new equipment we got
some new equipment in my
um hold on
[Music]
Ellie
all right guys I want to make sure
it says that I'm live okay I think it's
working
um okay so guys today I'm gonna be doing
some reactions like back in the day if
any of you remember I used to just come
on live and react to random things so I
want to know in the chat let me go
on YouTube
um
it's thumbnail this thumbnail is so ugly
Jesus Christ it's so ugly that is the
ugliest thumbnail I've ever seen in my
life
yeah but I I'm I've never been a
thumbnail Mastermind that has never been
my thing I could tell you like how I
like them but I just hate making
thumbnails I've always hated it okay so
we're gonna turn on my screen share
and then I want to do picture and
picture
I used to use a different software when
I would stream
yeah so guys I need some rules please
don't get me caught for copyright
I don't like pulling streams down
and if I does get pulled I'm gonna be
lazy I'm gonna not come back second
thing
um please don't react make me react to
anything that
is inappropriate okay I don't I don't
need that in my life third third
I don't know let me know in the chat
what I should react to I'm gonna be
checking on my phone maybe on the
computer but then it's you know
maybe yeah see this was me making my
thumbnail earlier
I'm telling you not okay here we got the
chat I just gotta make sure all right
first of all I want to check and make
sure the audio is working so
um
I'm gonna watch a video and I want to
know in the chat if you guys could hear
it
I've always been
Dubai right now always take uh they've
been hanging out
Logan what can you hear it
can you hear it
if you can't hear the video let me know
in the chat
I'll have to I'll have to phone blessing
if if we can't hear hey Ellie what do
you stop uh-uh doggy
chill out
okay should we let Ellie in the chat
I'll let Ellie on the video okay but if
you're annoying if you're annoying
I'm Gonna Let You Go on the chair
I'm Gonna Let You Go on the chair but if
you're annoying
you're getting kicked out
go ahead I know go ahead go ahead go
ahead what the [ __ ]
all right chill chill out all right
child
that is not what I meant okay I was
saying we could react together come here
okay
all right
yeah it's crazy I walked her to them and
she wouldn't walk
okay wait did you guys hear the video on
the chat let me see yes I can hear okay
good good come on Ellie
I was gonna let you in the video but now
you're being annoying okay
can you guys hear my dog breathing is
that really loud
um okay you want me to react to the
Cheyenne inner Cheyenne Reynolds
I want to go on this video they only
take women I've seen this already but
I'll react with you guys
um
you guys have to
okay
how bad is Ellie's breathing
how bad is Ellie's breathing let me know
in the chat also guys
um ah I said this in my morning coffee
thought no I did not get beat up I
dropped a glass out of our drink fridge
and it like shattered in my face you
know what maybe I'll fix the thumbnail
and do can you like screen capture how
do I screen capture
this is a new computer I don't
because I was like what I could do you
know what I'll go on Google
I just
I really don't like having a weak
thumbnail game guys it bothers me okay
um
Myron Cheyenne Reynolds
um okay
we're gonna steal this thumbnail
and put myself over it
sorry guys okay you can see how I am
really bad at making thumbnails I'd like
to say I would not really take advice
from me I could tell you how to make a
good thumbnail like what I would do but
like the actual
yeah okay so what I do is I go through
these on canva and I'm like
I just like this font so I'll be like
get rid of this get rid of that
get rid of that and then I'm like okay
upload file
uh
yeah so now we got this picture over
here and
yeah and what I'll do
let's get a picture of me reacting so
let's do some of these pictures are old
but I'm too lazy to take new ones
and let's take this is such an old
picture of me
that was so cute though
get rid of that get rid of that okay
[Music]
um
okay
uh maybe I should get one that's got
more of a
you can see me in it
I'll get two
cover them
something clickbait this is a game
this is I'll say a date
question mark
okay yeah this is better than we have
before not great I know I know not great
um I need to not share the screen so you
guys can't see the stream key sorry guys
um I know I should have did this before
I should have did this before I know
I know
just don't
um okay now where do I get the
can I fix the I
think I know I know
I already yeah I can't see the chat
right now but I I already know what
y'all are saying
okay let's go to lives edit this
I'm going to fix the change the
thumbnail
not that change
yeah okay better
I just feel like that thumbnail will do
better now
okay now I'm gonna react now I'm gonna
react so
all right
um picture in picture
so I'm here how do we feel about okay
[Music]
okay
you learned how to make a thumbnail yeah
I mean
making a thumbnail isn't necessarily
hard I just hate doing it okay
let's make this full screen
I wish I could make my box bigger I feel
like I'm too small here
but alas do you guys like me on this
side or this side
I feel like
okay
because I'm gonna have other girls in
there 100
I'm not gonna
look at my phone
why because I'm gonna have other girls
in there 100
all right tell me how the audio is guys
tell me how the audio is how we feeling
um
foreign
and I'm back new season new dates and to
be honest with you I'm not impressed
with the dating scene I think 99 of the
world's problems will be solved
females walk through life with their
body count on their
phone I've given some high scores I
thought we might as well do the deck
properly ah see I like this and I've
definitely given some low scores so like
I'll just say being as Caribbean
languages with nice jocks oh my God it's
time to find a man that can tickle the
boxes do you know what there wasn't
actually any red flags wow
Aaron Gaines I'm here to go on a date I
think for a debate I don't know don't
put a bag on my head and told me to show
up here and they just brought me here
oh we're in England so I can't invoke
the fifth damn what what do you guys say
when you don't want to incriminate
yourself here in England
okay no okay no comment
two to three I try to keep my retention
somewhat High I need a good rating on
what what do you guys use here
you guys use TripAdvisor it's a 1997.
what the hell
I'll say whatever that I can disclose
yeah I think so I don't know the dudes
that kidnapped me and brought me here
they said it would be fun I don't know
okay Cheyenne is so pretty oh my God
she's so pretty anyways I just need to
point that out
that girl is gorgeous
hey what's up how are you hello
you're gonna give me a hug or what okay
it's like he doesn't even laughs
chilling it's so nice thank you I try
hey me hug him I don't know why I've
done that the video sound is low
okay let me try
look at
did the thumbnail not change I swear I
changed the thumbnail let me I see it on
the side I have to kind of
oh yeah better okay
um
you said that let me
let me see if I can how I fix this I got
a call blessing
I got a call blessing
blessing blessing they're telling me
that my my video sound is low how do I
fix it
the chat
on YouTube
what
oh I'm the main one I was reacting to
the Myron and Cheyenne Reynolds video
what do you mean it's they're saying
it's not okay
they're saying they're saying that the
video volume slow
video yeah
okay so you
um
[Music]
are they messing with me
it's okay it's all right they're messy
with me
it's okay
it's okay
volume is okay like I'm playing it now
oh my God so they're just messing
how do I make my box bigger I want to be
bigger on the screen
what do you mean I didn't mess anything
up
I clicked on for the Box
okay well when are you gonna get here
okay I have some lamb for you
thank you
yeah I'll have lamb and rice
can you live with that
is is this an okay place to work
uh okay
um I'll see you I'll see you soon
okay bye
I cook for employees I cook for
employees
um Pro is your Tech at look it
get the volume up to 11. I don't know
can you hear my dog snoring
sometimes in life
look okay
um he said you guys were messing with me
all right let's let's go back to the
beginning let's go back
you guys better not be messing you
better not be messing chat
we're gonna go back I was like here
because typically if a guy is too
agreeable you can't
living yeah why
you don't tell the truth and you're just
being agreeable well he's trying to get
laid and he's trying to apply as well
you're I feel like it's quiet too I feel
like blessing
he is
Josh and
because I feel like this is quiet in my
ears but the thing is I click the sound
bar and it doesn't do anything so I'm
like what the [ __ ]
um blessings switched me to Apple and
I just up
sorry we are struggling live
um sound volume there we go
soft would never do this to me
man all right well this is the best I
can do chat I'm sorry
um
what do you mean to hear anything on the
video
well
I'm getting a FaceTime video
it was
[Music]
can you turn up the volume there can you
show me
um
here
this one
on the other one what do you mean this
one no no on the right on the right near
the screen
um
this one
not that one that's the mic for you the
one number three number three yeah
oh this is a little better oh yeah 100
it's oh that's better see I told you I
wasn't crazy
uh don't I'm tired of the gaslighting
okay bye
okay
um okay now I'm fixed I'm fixed oh [ __ ]
Jesus
also chat
um
okay
we're gonna watch this now
now you guys should
um
okay Myron
uh I'm a professional misogynist no I'm
just kidding
right love by some hated by many just on
the internet yeah on the internet yeah
we're both on the Internet it's a
strange life yeah I feel like okay this
is an observation and I'm not trying to
roast anyone I just have observation I
feel like when we've been on the
Internet or too long I have this problem
too our posture just starts to go
it just starts to
I have the same problem same issue seen
some videos
you're not a fan of me are you you know
I'm not a fan of many things yeah you
just happen to be in there maybe a
little bit why is that we disagree on
some things I think we might get on
though that's why I'm like interested
great off to a great start he hates me I
think it's very important to be able to
articulate your views and if you don't
agree with someone it doesn't mean you
have to hate them but you know but I
think being too agreeable is not good
especially as a man because typically if
a guy is too agreeable you can't trust
them living yeah why because all men
want to get laid and if you don't tell
the truth and you're just being
agreeable well he's trying to get laid
and he's trying to lie as well so well
at least the man actually admits all men
are trying to get laid oh yeah 100 yeah
I mean that's just common sense it does
how bad is my dog snoring in the chat
how about is my dog snoring in the chat
absolutely pointless to have a female
friend no no it's not a pointless type
of female friends very pointless 100 why
would guys sit there and be friends with
girls it's pointless stupid so you don't
have any female friends absolutely not
it's a waste of time how is it a waste
of time because women don't offer much
utility to you as a guy what makes you
think that
well I mean if you get in some kind of
fight she can't do nothing what you're
going to do to me oh my God
if anything she's a liability that's
what I'm trying to say like I'd fight a
woman for you if you're my man I don't
want my girl to be involved in any type
of physical conversation that's that's
not her job that's my job so I look at
it like if I'm with a girl and I'm
supposed to protect her and provide for
her Etc I want that to be my woman I'm
not going to give that type of energy to
like a friend that's stupid why am I
going to put my life on the line for a
girl that doesn't even suck my dick wait
but is that too much there I don't I
think you should just be able to have a
friendship with women though well well
firstly it's not always like men versus
women so I kind of feel like having
female friends will give you that
balance to understand like there's
actually nice normal women okay
is there any utility to female friends
hmm
as a guy I mean
it just depends I mean some guys
Ellie
they use the friends as like
pre-selection to get laid and that's how
they do it I think they argue that's not
an effective way because all the girls
know their friend zone but I'm like ah
I don't know I've seen
um like I can think of two people that
are dating right now that met through me
because I was friends with the girl and
the guy
so you know some people yes I don't know
aren't just trying to sleep with you
like for your money or everything like
that we bring a lot of value
I've interviewed almost 1600 women now
at this point and I would say without a
shadow without women are absolutely
terrible at being understanding what it
takes to be attractive to women as a man
yeah that's true we have no idea oh my
God
should I kick my dog out let me know in
the chat should I kick my dog out of my
room
one or two one or two in the chat
[Music]
um
one or two in the chat should I kick my
dog out I can't tell how loud it is for
you guys but
yeah I would say
viewing the show for six months no women
have no idea what women like
like none none none
their advice typically is not good at
all 1 600 women
four women men carry like a lot of like
hurt and they push it on women okay her
in what way yeah I think it's because
like for example this Intel culture
which like respectfully like your
podcast really brings to life you're
just projecting onto women unnecessarily
because there's a lot of good women like
I myself would say I'm a good woman I
don't do anything wrong I'm very loyal
I'm a kind woman and a lot of men will
make the Assumption I've actually talked
to Cheyenne a little bit
um she's actually very nice she's very
nice I don't she's not the exact way she
is on camera
um I'd like to say she's very nice
hold on okay there's a podcast like
yours and people and men like you to
then push that one to me I'm this kind
of woman I'm a gold digger and I'm
Memphis and that and I'm not no no but
this is this is the thing like
you might be kind and you might be loyal
for the right guy but like the thing is
our nature is the same and the West is
still the West so even if you're a nice
woman you're still in the west and
you're still a modern woman
um yeah
well the reality is would it be fair to
say that most men I mean you said
there's a whole insult culture Etc would
it be fair to say that most guys are
losers and don't don't really measure up
I personally don't think that but a
thousand but I'm sorry no I personally
don't like genuinely I don't okay okay
politically correct I'll keep it real
since you don't want to most guys I'll
be honest are fat losers and don't have
leadership qualities and there's a whole
bunch of reasons for that and most women
quite frankly are terrible they're
[ __ ] fat rude crass whatever it may be
and most of them don't qualify for
relationship and most guys don't qualify
to be the leader of set relationships I
think it goes on both parts okay the men
are weak and the women there's a bunch
of issues there I agree I agree I do
think
women cause those issues like I think we
I think men like by and large are the
same
they're just like less motivated almost
because it's like
the juice isn't really worth the squeeze
anymore oh well we basically highlight
on our podcasters need to be the best
version of yourself and I think the
thing is is that guys are yearning for
this because we've been lying to men for
the better part of five to six decades
about what being masculine and strong
actually is we've been demonizing it
when in reality guys need to become
stronger because no woman wants a weak
man Even though girls say dumb [ __ ] like
oh well you know I want you to be
emotionally intelligent you get in tune
real feelings or whatever it's all a lie
to see no there's a but I personally
would like a man that's emotionally
available
and emotionally intelligent but it's not
me saying like I want you crying all the
time so I mean it's true though like so
I understand what you're saying but at
the same time you have to give some room
for men because now like see this is
what I mean like when women we don't
understand
what when like what makes men attractive
to women like
it's not to say you can never ever ever
cry or be emotionally available to your
girl ever but the point that men are
making is that you only have so much
before she's disgusted by it and each
girl is different and you don't know
what your girl is
FaceTime and is a blessing calling me
again
see okay I'm gonna call him back I'm
gonna call him back
oh
yeah okay well
anyways yeah so that's my whole that's
my whole point yeah
is
you still wait hold on sorry mistake oh
serious like issue we tell guys not to
be vulnerable in front of your girl you
know you you go ahead you're going to be
vulnerable You're Going to shed a tear
whatever you do that around other men
that understand you know the whole point
when I first heard this I was like shut
up like you know of course in a 50-year
marriage you're gonna be vulnerable
sometimes like that was my initial
reaction but then I thought about it and
I was like oh he's saying that
it's just at a balance of probabilities
it's better to go to the men
because they're not going to be repulsed
by it
and women tend to be and you know it's
not a fun part of our nature but you
know we we all crazy we all crazy so
it's like we'd rather we'd rather have a
guy that can lead us through our
emotions because we operate on emotion
men in general operate on logic
experience women don't understand the
male experience at all and it goes to
show like when I said earlier when you
put the girl in a male perspective I
want you to pick up this girl they
always fall flat on their face because
women are in a privileged position where
they don't have to necessarily
understand what it takes to attract the
man because men come to them for me as a
partner I would want to be able to give
my man a safe space to be able to be
vulnerable and it's like but not
completely like oh my Partnerships
aren't real
50 50 is not real
cry all the time but just so he knows
like it's like things are okay
you know like oh guys I have to take the
lamb out of the oven I'm sorry I have to
go one second I'll be back I'll be back
one second
ow
your dog
all right I'm back y'all I had to take
the lamb out of the oven I'm sorry I'm
sorry I just needed a second okay
partnership there no it's not a
partnership that's another common lie in
modern day dating it's not important I
want a partnership though question for
you do you want a man that's taller than
you idealistically speaking I do the
property because I like to wear Hills I
like to be saying fantastic do you want
to gather stronger than you
yeah do you want a guy that makes more
money than you oh should I get it
okay well oh [ __ ] hold on I gotta
um hold on I forgot
um
hold on let me refer to message
topic tonight
it art can relationships
really be 50 50. that'd be a good topic
topic what is a 50 50 relationship
look like that okay sorry guys you
wanted to make at least your equivalent
if not preferably better remember this
is your ideal guy yeah okay do you want
a guy that's more confident than
yourself
yeah more experience than yourself yeah
okay you basically describe the superior
so you expect this guy to come in and
have a partnership with you whatever he
might Excel on I'll also add value in
other ways because it's not always about
being physically on the same on par with
that person just for certain
requirements like you can't buff a baby
you know yeah so we complement each
other in other ways and so we're still
equal in that sense men and women are
not equal at all
metal that's another fallacy that we
have in modern day dating culture which
leads so many women Australia we're not
the same there's certain things that men
can do that women can that can't do and
vice versa and we're different and we're
designed to complement each other and I
don't believe in Partnerships I think
men come in and Lead women follow
um and I agree with that
like
it's kind of weird because you don't
really think about it
um I don't know when you're blue pill or
you're just like looking at the world
but the relationships that I admire the
most the woman follows the man and like
follows his lead and it doesn't really
seem to work when the woman leads
because she just kind of like busts his
balls all the time find it funny because
women typically want a man and here's
the thing what you just described is
what every girl wants but they think
that they're going to go into religion
with a guy that's better than them every
single metric and it's going to be an
equal partnership or 50 50. it doesn't
work that way there's always a leader
there's always a decider and for it to
work the man's got to be in leadership
role never the woman women can't lead
anything here we come nothing it creates
too much pressure on you as a man then
because if you want to be this like
matching man do you not think that's
going to cause a lot of strain on a
relationship pressure creates diamonds
because here's the thing women are just
the cherry on top like you you should
have already he is right he's right look
at
if if a woman's the Center of Your World
then
the guys that women want to be with
you just saying [ __ ] to them because
they're they have so many
so it's like like a woman shouldn't be
the center of a guy's world I agree by
the time she comes into the picture you
know you should have already conquered a
boardroom or conquered some kind of
physical labor played Sports at some
point in your life endured some kind of
stress like men need to go through pain
men must become women are men must
become being a loser is unacceptable if
you're broke fat or you don't got
yourself together that's your problem
yeah but then that true true I agree
with that
I wonder if he says that
to the other way
Walter or whatever
chunky
like you would complain about women
because you'd say oh they only come for
like the glory of it like and not the
graph so I'd rather be with someone that
I'm building with I've never I've never
I've never said that women build I
actually say the contrary I say women
don't build they move in yeah but and I
acknowledge that called reality 100 I
tell guys they need to build the castle
so that she can come in and you know you
know what I want to I'm gonna call a
couple people
let's see
something
I just want to check something
I want to see if I'm going to call like
three of my female friends and ask them
what they'd prefer
just hold on
sure forwarded to it okay just random
who else could I call and ask
kind of FaceTime audio this [ __ ]
because
there she's in the U.S
damn I'm getting left on
[Music]
um
see a lot of the girls in the US are
probably working now
mm-hmm
no she's too crazy I can't
um let me try her
she'd be at work I think she works from
home though so let's see
I swear to God if I get left on if I get
left
on delivered for three
it's going to hurt my existence
oh my God
damn
[Music]
sad
is there anyone else
because
um
hmm
sad
let me see what my dad picks I'm gonna
ask my dad actually what's better
[Music]
I bet my dad will answer I'm at my dad
will answer he wouldn't leave me on he
wouldn't not answer he wouldn't do that
to me
he wouldn't he wouldn't do that to me
he wouldn't
oh okay thank God quick question dad
um just so you know I'm I'm on a stream
okay
like go ahead you know okay I'm on a
stream I'm on a stream I just had a
quick question
um so if you if you had to pick okay so
if I had two guys trying to marry me
they are all the same okay but one was
my age he's 26 and he he was like
working hard and like building something
and the other one was 36 and he was
already like rich
which one would you say would be better
to pick
all things equal
yeah things are never equal
um I like uh see that that's a hard one
because
one's a guarantee kind of one's not so I
would go with a 26 year old in my case
but in your case I'm not sure I would
in your case I like hard work I think
the best thing
and so
but
if the tire Gap isn't it's a big
midnight dude he said 20 years that say
no question 26 year old so if it was if
it was if it was if it was 46 you'd say
to pick the 26 year old
why would you why would you say to pick
the 26 year old
[Laughter]
no guarantees in life yeah you're right
but still it's still 20 years plus you
don't have much to comment people
excluding another equal a group of
different Generations like me dating a
30 year old or something like that I
just didn't generation people
oh it's a different generation of
everything uh so
have you have you ever seen have you
ever seen a large age Gap work
have you ever seen a large age Gap work
like long term because you're old you've
actually seen people get together oh my
gosh
um
the answer question I mean I get Dennis
Dennis the salad you know them they've
seen they're like 20 years apart oh
really
yeah and I think they've done pretty
well Sally and the the lady the lady in
Florida
the lady in Florida
okay I was just curious because they
were asking if women would rather like
build with a guy or they'd rather just
like pick a guy that's there and that's
why I think he has it already most most
of them most women most women would pick
a guy that has it already
God for sure why not why you have to go
over yet
why do we have it my phone with it I
mean I'm gonna be sarcastic I don't
agree with it but I just don't know why
you wouldn't as a girl
do you think do you think do you think
my perspective is different because like
I grew up with money
already oh and you're building something
and you're building something yeah
yeah
well that's I was just wondering because
I feel like money has I feel like
what
who
it looks who's baby daddies
all the time baby oh oh there yeah what
did they have that looks because if they
had money they'd probably still be there
oh that's a good question I could ask on
a show be like how much did your baby
daddy make
um
yeah
so I mean that I mean so
God
so
so no I am so no that's that's the
problem so that's a lot of questions
there to answer
um okay
I was just wondering
okay good luck have fun okay thanks Dad
love you bye
that's what my dad said what'd you guys
think
um
I want to see
um
is there any other girl I should call
that was kind of sad Everyone's Watching
Me be left let's see obscene
hmm
so I think I'd prefer to date someone
going there than there
but then people will be like cap cap cap
but I think that's only because like
there's a guarantee that he'd get there
and my like see what I'm saying but yeah
okay things up here and there in your
Castle but at the end of the day you got
to build the structure women aren't
going to build it with you those days
are done women some women do though like
a lot of women do some no a few the ones
I know I would say a minority a majority
want a guy that comes pre-assembled yeah
but want and can get two different
questions what what percent got it got
got a chance with a guy that's
pre-assembled none is he talking about
so we got to go off with the majority
knock on my North wait hold on actually
I have one other person that I'd like to
call
[Music]
um
so yeah let's go I'm advising men how to
you know operate in a daily Marketplace
I can't tell them look out for this 10
that wants to build with you no the
reality is most women want you to come
pre-assembled and to be honest the most
attractive and youngest women that have
the most options they definitely want
you to come pre-assembled women want
winners they sit at the finish line and
pick the winners
where did you grow up I grew up in New
Britain Connecticut
two hours north of New York City so what
was your upbringing like
great parents were together the whole
time stable I had a sister brother
um so I mean they're still alive now I
haven't said had yeah like they're gone
yeah
um yeah I mean I grew up went to high
school played basketball in high school
played video games had still had my
childhood friends to this day I would
say I grew up like in a pretty good
situation we didn't grow up with money
right we grew up fairly you know poor
little you know lower middle class my
parents struggled especially in the
beginning yeah I mean I wouldn't trade
it for the world I think it's important
for young men to grow up like struggling
yeah
you know what's interesting my family
was always like the had the most money
but we spent it like we were very frugal
growing up I mean we always had a big
house I'm gonna say that we always
always had a big house but when it came
to like
um I don't know clothes like we always
had to hand-me-downs we never flew on
vacation we drove we didn't have cable
TV and I just feel like you shouldn't
spoil children sometimes in the red pill
they'll be like spoil the women they
shouldn't have hard stuff either and I'm
like ah I don't know then you kind of
get a little spoiled brat it's you it
builds character you have to do it how
will you raise a son with your mindset
I'm just curious tonight uh I would
raise my son to not be a victim uh you
know I'm at a point now where a very
successful financially but my son would
not see any of this money at all I would
make him get it out the mud because
um like we discussed before trust fund
babies typically don't know what to do
in life and how to you know they don't
understand and appreciate the value of a
dollar and I thank my dad for instilling
in that man that in me earlier I mean my
first job was at McDonald's and I got
fired and I quickly learned that I
didn't want to be in the service
industry but it made me appreciate
people in the service industry so I
cannot imagine
what is this by the way this is like a
tonic wine when I drink I'm like quite a
mellow person chill completely in the
mood you're not an angry drunk no I'm
not actually no okay that's good I'd be
the worst angry oh Auntie Jenny is
calling me
I said Auntie Jenny is calling me a call
um
foreign
hey Auntie
hi
what um what did you call what's up
no I was just watching your shirt
being frugal
and I think a lot of women don't want to
be frugals
no it's true
the way that you're just because they've
got the money they I think they
explained it they did it you know it
doesn't mean you have to spend it
stupidly
I mean we always thought you said if you
got kids they always pass the clothes
down so it's normally the oldest that
gets near close unless you're going out
yeah I was lucky I was the oldest girl
you know we always used to go the
cheapest way and take apart lunch have a
picnic on the way and I think if I if I
had money I would still do the same
thing I think that's how come I'm so
Frugal because I learned from my mom
had to be frugal and then you either
spend money on the important things
if you're if you're free you can come
watch it with me
[Music]
get away
you're right you're just a bit far
no because I know that you're live
aren't you you're live yeah yeah of
course
your daddy I'm laughing your dad's right
I
thought that's a merry
married a rich man because when you
struggle together with your mentality if
you believe in your man use help him
build up his business and I think when
couples struggle and suffered together
if they're meant to be together it just
makes them stronger and they learn to
appreciate more than left more that
they've got so I think the reason why
your family was so Frugal because they
know how they got that money they didn't
just make it overnight they weren't
bloody hard and sacrifice for it whereas
if you meet a man who's already made it
or you're gonna do sprints
mm-hmm
no there's nothing to work towards I
think that yeah couples that fight
together and do things like that I think
that they they're the ones that last
so I'd go with the poor man but I know a
lot of women will go with a rich man but
I'm with your dad on that
well my dad always talks about like if
it's a big age Gap you're not going to
be alive for the last half of your life
and I feel like there's I was like I
never finished
yeah yeah that's what my dad was saying
so I was like oh never thought of that
because I found out he was a cheater you
just saved me a lifetime
love is I don't know peace
huh
that's what you need to think about I
took the look you choose really really
old they eventually you're gonna have to
start cleaning it
never thought about that yeah I mean I
don't know anyone with an age Gap that's
lasted like long term but I'm not saying
they can't I've just never the only
people I know it's like only been a
couple years so it's kind of too soon to
say
[Music]
but I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna finish
this video you're welcome to come by
on joining because your dad was on our
fault yet
you're a dad okay
all right bye
I love Auntie Jenny I don't drink
I don't Haram see we have you never
drunk I have I definitely have but I
mean it's not really conducive to my
life goals at the moment so I don't
really drink like that it's just more
self-awareness isn't it yeah I mean I
stopped drinking too fun packed man you
you can't afford to have things that
clout your you know your inhibition or
your ability to go out there and create
and become a better version of yourself
and I think like that's why I'm really
big on like not drinking doing drugs any
of that stuff you've got to be focused
all the time so how do you find dating
then with the way that you are I mean
when you understand uh the code it's you
know Plug and Play it's like okay just
deal with the girl size her up figure
out what kind of trick she is and then
bam you know you already know kind of
how to how to move so like what's the
code depends on I wonder how I would be
sized up
and please chat don't say nobody's
trying to size you up anyway all right
all right I'm not everyone's cup of tea
but if I was I just want to know what
I'd be sized up
I just can't imagine any girls like
gonna want to be like hug me at the
beginning of the day
okay you got to be able to adapt based
on the woman that you're sitting across
the table from yeah I have the female
codes in my sleeves I know pretty much
what they all are okay so how are you
adopting to me right now you want me to
be honest yeah of course okay I want the
code now and then I'll ask the code
again by the end of it yeah I would say
uh recreational use only no offense so
what's like the old how many codes is
there well it depends on the record wow
wow nope
you know you if you deal with a girl
that's younger that's in her prime years
well you got to understand that she's
more you know inclined to look for fun
if you're dealing with a girl that is in
her mid-20s a lot of times and she might
be pursuing you know it depends on the
girl but she might be pursuing some type
of stability or some security and you
got to play at that angle or if you deal
with a girl that's a little bit older
late 20s 30s or not nine out of ten
times she's going to want some type of
security if she hasn't gotten there
already code it's not even that deep
like either you like them or not you
don't need to put them in categories so
what kind of woman do you want sorry
um let's be honest ladies we have
categories too let's just let's just be
real Let's do let's just be real you
know damn well when we meet a guy we put
him in a box
I personally my boxes are yes no maybe
yes no maybe it's like immediate yes
immediate now
maybe gotta get to know this one a
little more
Yes No Maybe
and then the chat will be like wow
nevermind sorry
you guys
sometimes you'll be coming for me for
everything it's like damn
I can't say anything anyway sorry
I mean I could deal with whatever my
thing is I need her to come into my life
and be an asset and not a liability most
girls are liabilities to be honest do
you think I think the right woman though
could like really just compliment you
and make you like Progressive also I
will read super chats if I see them
sorry I have the thing
if you have things you want to say you
can Super Chat it or not yeah whatever
but I'm just saying
I'm working for a living here you know I
want to get blessing a monopod but they
really
he really spent a lot on my credit card
last month me and blessing got beef
right now
we got beef because it was a lot so
we're kind of on a budget but you know
anyways well you got to train them no
you haven't in order to train someone
you need them to listen I'm telling you
no woman is listening to you like most
girls come into your life like and if
you don't know what you're doing she's
going to come in as a liability 100 no
you don't train them though you have to
try it's like training a dog you
wouldn't do that oh here we go I knew
that was good no but it's true though
it's not not training it's not something
like once again it's just seeing this
person actually I actually do think you
sort of trained women
I
I think good women are trainable sorry
sorry well okay but showing the person
respect it's not training so I look at
it like if I'm gonna have a girlfriend
and she's going to be my girl and she's
going to have my title well she's got to
be trained to rise up to a certain level
because I'm going to make her into an
asset buy me a bag do this blah blah
blah take me on trips whatever when they
haven't earned it so you got to try
de-train those bad behaviors out of that
girl and make her an asset into your
life versus a liability most guys don't
understand their value they bring their
own to their life they give her
everything she hasn't earned it she
doesn't respect them she's walking all
over him he's right this is just facts
this is just look at this is just facts
he's speaking fat that's true that's
absolutely true women
you can't give girls everything we then
we don't respect it and it's kind of
like
somewhat similar for guys like guys kind
of want to chase a little bit too you
know take the relationship I know the
guys would be like no no no guys don't
at all and I'm just thinking like
okay I'm sorry guys
would not be all these books that sell
so well that women have wrote with like
women dating advice if men don't like
the chase a little bit I understand
simps maybe it's just the Sims okay
but some of y'all do okay I'm just being
honest I'm just being honest most people
don't like things that are given to them
for free they don't respect it you're
not getting socks tonight blah blah blah
he's so rude obviously this is your
experience so I can't argue that but I
mean this is this is this is biology
women are hardwired to extract resources
for men it's been that way since the
beginning of time biology rules
everything guys they could sit there and
say oh but I'm doing this and my truth
blah blah blah biology rules you there's
one truth there's no such thing as my
truth female typical blah blah blah
trash
no but I kind of feel like from my
experience if I've gone into if I'm
going into someone's life I would want
to add value so I wouldn't really take
things and I kind of feel when you what
did you just say two seconds ago you
said in my EXP erience my comment come
in and I added value yeah that's you
majority of women come in meet the guy
okay what can I get from this guy okay
this guy's a cent I'll just take him out
on dinner dates he could pay I'm never
gonna smash him another guy this guy's
hot you know I can smash him I can hang
out with him this guy he has some
utility he's a plumber okay I could do
my Plumbing but I'll give him a BJ once
girls put guys in rolls it's your job as
the man to make sure to you're the top
guy and you got the main role where
you're not investing too much and she's
investing more in you girls own respect
men that they invest in the girl always
has to like the guy more than she likes
him no I think he works better the other
way around when the guy likes to grow
more yeah that doesn't make sense why
doesn't it because women want a man is
better than them so how do I look if I'm
better than you and I'm sitting here
Chasing After You doesn't make sense
women only respect men that they chase
it doesn't work the other way around
once again with this like new I
I hate that that's true but come on like
how many times have we heard on Tick
Tock oh I only like the guys that don't
like me yeah we like being zoomed we do
we like to work for it I can't I don't
make the game I just tell you what it is
for women we don't want to we don't
categorize friend zone Orbiter Chad
husband foodie Dave
for a man knows if he's going to treat
you like an option see here's the thing
we can say that women are changing
whatever but we're all slaves to our
biology women are 100 okay with sharing
men it's been that way since the
beginning of time it's I would say it's
even more apparent now with Instagram
dating apps Etc a minority of men are
getting a majority of the women and
women are okay with that I mean walk
into a nightclub walk into a nightclub
it's probably one of the most carnal
representations of human nature all the
women are sitting in one section with a
bunch of the the guys that have the
highest perceived status in that social
setting versus all the other guys are
out there in general admission
struggling women always gravitate
towards the best guys and they're
willing to share those guys so what's
your type my type fit feminine friendly
yeah it's submissive and coachable and
coaching oh come on Myron you're not
gonna add in with the fat ass
boobs at like come on
you got I'm just let's just be real here
you guys are like I have no type
I usually have a little bit of a type a
little bit like there's something
to be trained
you've got to train women man I I know
that sounds terrible he's still talking
she's like I thought this was a date
women don't like it when they get
criticized if I go on a podcast and I
say you know what guys you need to stop
being bums you need to get your money on
point not being fat poses Etc they
actually admire and respect that people
are in the FL in the chat flame emojis
whatever I go on rants on the guys all
the time I'm sweating going crazy it's
like I'm hey bro I know you like to chit
chat and I do too I really need
like-minded female friends but don't
know how to find them can you help me
out oh girl I don't know
you think I know
ah
I wish
um
yeah I got no advice sorry some
questions I have good answers too
because some of my friends really don't
agree with me
or even know what this red pill stuff is
I don't
yeah
DM me you know I preach I think she's
trying to grow me but what she doesn't
know is I'm a black belt in this I've
dealt with 10 girls like her at the same
time on my podcast so she's gonna take
an L women rarely get held accountable
for their poor decisions men do though
men have to live in reality women are
afforded the privilege of being
delusional so when a guy criticizes a
woman oh my God right if you don't
believe me think about it if a dude's
fat we just call him fat you're a loser
huh form is fat love your curves girl
you go she's rude and obnoxious oh you
know what they just can't handle you
you're strong and independent fierce we
have all these terms to cover up
female inadequacies but we don't have
these same terms for men I think it just
a lot of it comes from like narcissistic
behavior from men and myself women are
far more narcissistic than that no true
yeah okay and you can answer this
question so easy who's the more
narcissistic gender who is more addicted
to social media social media damn nears
narcissism
who's more addicted women women who post
more selfies women who post more ass
shots women
women
yeah
women can be so I'm not I'm not
disputing but I kind of feel like with
men that are taking because I'll tell
you Cheyenne men have to live in reality
they have to live in reality like men
will get made fun of from a young age
and told that they ain't [ __ ] some of
y'all didn't have brothers to bully you
and it shows it shows
us and power you it gives you the
opportunity to try and to to dominate no
but no but this is men earn narcissism
men do not earn a right to be narcissist
cystic like just shut up
men earn confidence and arrogance women
don't women are born with their value
that's true I'm curious
he's gonna make the Box bigger on the
live are you here blessing
are you here don't don't scare me
you'll control it from here oh wow
he can control it guys blessing's not
here and he's going to control the Box
all right wait for it this is exciting
it's like I swear to God if you run up
on me I'm gonna
oh look and I'm moving I'm bigger woohoo
must earn their value oh but sorry my
question is do you think that
um a woman that's a 10 like 9 10 has the
right to be cocky
because that's like what women are more
judged on is like their beauty and their
youth so if a girl's a 22 and hot does
she have a right to be cocky because a
lot of times they'll be like oh you have
an accomplished [ __ ] or you haven't done
[ __ ] like why would you be cocky but
then they'll say your accomplishments
don't matter which I I totally
understand what they're saying I would
just my question is
does the 22 year old hot chick have a
right to be cocky oh my God that's so
cool blessings moving it on screen wow
that's arrogant more than likely he's
probably accomplished something when a
woman's arrogant nine out of ten times
she hasn't accomplished anything she
just has a bunch of DM thanks for the
content Pearl you are so pretty thank
you
so tired of y'all call me average in the
chat look it it might be true but we
don't need to tell me every single day
okay I get it I get it average looking I
get it y'all have told me again and
again and again but it's like I I know
can we just
I know anyway sorry
I'm still a woman okay
see this is the way what does the chat
say she has the right to be cocky but
women
that are sixes to eights all say that
they're tens where does the confidence
come from a nine can be cocky but that
drops them to a six so they should stop
I was just that's my question
okay so we don't need to we don't need
to argue in the chat about whether or
not I'm average
that a lot of modern day women have they
lack I know I know I have I have my cut
on my nose I I hit yeah I didn't get
beat up
some people I saw this thing in the chat
that was like
she's covering for her her Tyrone or her
whatever and like he hit her like she's
a real woman I'm like what
how the hell this is like a scratch it's
not a hit there would be a bruise like
my face would be
if I got hit by a dude second second
I don't know if that would make okay I'm
just gonna
thinking skills
women tend to go off of their feelings
versus what's real they go off I had
lamb I'm kind of hungry
can I get lamb guys
can I get lamb
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna watch for two
more minutes I'm gonna go get my lamb in
a second heels are not the reels what a
girl is supposed to do is come into a
man's life see where he's deficient okay
I noticed that you like to go to the gym
at this time I'm gonna make sure that
you have a protein shake with as many
grams of protein as you need just get a
pie
I'm gonna okay but a PA doesn't like a
wife makes a house a home and this is
the thing like a personal assistant yeah
it's just not the same it just it's
different when your personal assistant's
doing [ __ ] for you
okay I'm gonna go get food hold on I'm
gonna go get food I'll be right back
okay
foreign
okay
I'm back
all right
I need a little more seasoning on this
I'm sorry guys I'm sorry I'm sorry
[Music]
I don't know
and yeah
[Music]
okay back
okay
I like spicy
that's done and I'm a deductive Problem
Solver I'm able to be observant because
that's women's gift is being observant
of social situations that's why women
are socially Superior to men
okay it's never sex is when a guy
mentions something about a woman that's
positive so a woman's job is to use that
social calibration that they have that
they're Superior to men in and be able
to be like okay this guy's deficient in
this and deficient of this Etc let me
come in compliment make this guy operate
he's already operating at 95 I'm going
to get him to 102. and when you're at a
high level already that extra two three
four five percent is what helps you beat
the competition this guy is dangerous
women will do that a lot of women will
give you that life that will give you
that balance they will compliment you
but they're not going to just do it
until you
question am I socially Superior
on the podcast
I'm just asking I'm just asking serious
you know because men like to play the
field for a very long time when you're
with a guy of value you got to
understand that he has a leverage not
you you're applying to be his girlfriend
I wear the highway baby because at the
end of the day when you can replace a
girl that's when she respects you it's
on the woman to prove to me that she's
worthy of a relationship that's where a
lot of girls make a mistake they'll sit
there and say I'm good I'm loyal blah
blah blah blah I want to you know see
how you do before you get promoted I'm
not going to give a girl the position of
a secretary or underboss right or second
in charge of my company unless she's
been vetted she's got to work her way up
the problem is that we give women CEO
jobs when they haven't proven themselves
and they don't respect the job who's
listening to this man so you're here's
the thing you're looking at equality
from a human perspective I'm not saying
that men are better than women from a
human perspective I'm saying that men
are leaders
he's right
let's say I just use NBA players because
I just feel like those are guys
entertainers athletes they just
have women on tap I'm sorry
that was those the wives are all getting
chewed on they know it
we don't I don't say right or wrong I
can't tell the world how to be that's my
opinion on it I can't
Ali
I'm eating
therefore we cannot be equal when you're
on the battlefield right and the
lieutenant or whoever the the commanding
officer is on the battlefield you're not
equal to him as you know a regular
Soldier he is the leader you're not
equal but there's a reason there's a
hierarchy to dictate order if the woman
is equal to the guy well who's going to
make the final decision nothing gets
done by a committee they're always
asking Pearl was born a bit ugly it's
unfortunate why
rude rude but hitting the gym styling
hair and clothing can up her game
[Laughter]
look it I can't really help how my face
looks
I was just born like that
we just not call me ugly anymore can we
just not I just appreciate it
who am I talking about I'm just getting
old
I'm just tired of this one leader in
charge there's a reason why there's a
president there's a CEO Etc both people
can't be Alphas as they say the problem
is this women are confused about what
men actually want they think a CEO a
boss a business owner ambitious uh
competitive woman we don't give a [ __ ]
about none of that stuff men don't care
about that and I would argue the more
money a man makes the less he cares
about his woman's ability to earn money
men and women are not the same women
basically become the very men that they
want to attract yeah but the thing is
why so men like I find the memo say that
they do you guys think you are what you
attract yes or no
because I feel like that was a bad piece
of dating advice that I got like become
what you want to attract Ellie
can you chill the F out you're gonna get
you're getting kicked out
you're getting kicked out
um
all right I'm gonna give you a little
piece of meat to leave me the hell alone
okay
that's what I'm gonna do come here
yeah leave me alone leave me alone you
crazy dog it's on the ground look turn
up
sorry she was driving me nuts
women that have ambition to start it was
what makes the light to get laid no I
wouldn't say it's even a lie it's a lady
it's not because for me like whenever
like I've dated and stuff like that a
lot of men say they like the fact that I
am ambitious that I haven't no but I'm
saying in general a lot of men get
irritated like nowadays like so you're
so you're dating all these women and
you're gonna say all these women do this
is they do nothing and they expect but
that's the qualities that a traditional
woman would bring she'd want a man to do
things for her so but here's the thing
she look it
I'm sorry men don't care about your
career I do well
I would say I'm pretty successful for my
age you know guys don't give a [ __ ] it
does not make me more attractive to a
guy they're like yeah cool and
they don't care they just don't care I
can't make the world
it would be helpful to me if they cared
but I can't make them care yeah
people mess that man's life so do you
want a relationship
monogamous
so how many girlfriends do you want
I mean as many as I can I mean I
probably have four wives I think I could
do four this man wants four wives he's
going back 500 years four wives the way
to go because if one acts stupid you can
go ahead and get another one really yeah
yeah why okay I want to be a minute I
asked my dad about this four wives he
said have these guys deal with one
before they get four
I said dad you're too blue pill you're
blue pill
most guys are monogamous are monogamous
out of force la la my dad would never la
la
if I land at 100 dudes and I said listen
man
you keep your girlfriend
right no don't line up my dad or my
brothers I don't want to hear it she's
not gonna care he's gonna take it every
time most guys have to kind of concede
to what their girl wants should I call
my brother I'm gonna call him is he
gonna lie to me let me know in the chat
um
Adam
okay let's call them let's call him
will he answer
I've been bad for answering today
laughs
hmm
damn
people are leaving me on
anyways
wait with the brick
stupid quote happy wife happy life I
think that's the dumbest quote ever I
mean it's a good quote absolutely not
why because a woman's job is to please
the man not the other way around a
woman's job
women are pleased by being with the best
man
in in the area that women are pleased by
you being the best version of yourself
as a man gains more status success
income Etc the woman wins she's all his
success she benefits from that it's not
the same when a woman makes more money
I died I'm not sure
yeah because women women don't like guys
don't care about your success like
they're happy for you they're like cool
babe but
are they attracted to it no no I don't
make the world I don't I'm just telling
you what it is
five dollar Super Chat Pearl isn't ugly
plain but still cute
she gets points for chewing with her
mouth closed and being tall always
wanted a woman I could go up on go up on
ew what
ew
anyways
um
hey yeah yeah
yeah Etc and she starts to outgrow her
man she's gonna look for a better man
men and women are not the same but some
women we are emotional beans like we
will stay with them no but we will stay
with the man like if a man loves us and
his lawyer we will stay really is that
why women initiate an overwhelming
amount of the breakups
um
women also one of the number one
indicators we're going to leave your ass
is if we start out start out earning you
we get a promotion at work
like yeah because they're emotional and
they're loyal no women are the list most
disloyal creatures
which is okay
yeah and I hated that when I first heard
it I was like what no I'm loyal
he's right he's right if a dude's
bumming at for so long at some point
you're out you're out you're not gonna
take care of him
so do you like the whole sugar baby kind
of Lifestyle manic after the woman
that's you no no that sounds like it
like you want to be this provider so
that sounds like it well here's the
thing but then you moan about women for
doing that so you know I accept that
women are are um hypergamous creatures
that want to get their needs met through
men I accept this reality and I've
accepted it a long time ago I'm a firm
believer that men need to be men men
need to lead women follow men pay for
dates men should provide men should be
red winners I think women working should
be elective I don't think it should be
mandatory these guys definitely a sugar
daddy
look at no girl's gonna argue with that
to work for fun
um I've always
never minded working
but [ __ ]
no no girl's gonna argue so guys all the
time go on sugar sites and use them to
date because there's a lot of girls on
there that aren't necessarily how do I
say this
sugar babies that are just looking to be
taken care of and paid in allowance
there's a good amount of girls on there
that make their own money and or just
want to deal with a guy that has his
stuff together let's be honest tender
Bumble hands these traditional dating
apps they fail 90 plus percent of them
and the stats show that how you meet a
woman matters a lot more than meeting
the woman what I mean by that is that
women place a lot of importance in the
context under which they meet you it's
my job as a man to not get finessed
that's true that is very true
I'm way more likely to talk to a guy if
I meet him through mutual friends than
if I met him like through Instagram
like I get a lot of DMS on Instagram
and
it's kind of overwhelming it's like
I don't even know what to do with them
like I don't know you guys were like oh
that's a hard problem to have Pearl I
know
it's just more like
I'm afraid I'm gonna get killed
sometimes
and I'm like if someone kills me off
Instagram anyways anyways I'm gonna just
yeah oh boohoo okay okay
look it
and it's different if someone messages
you that knows your friends but it's
like the more mutual people the less
likely that you're crazy and I feel like
I don't know what the evolutionary thing
behind that is but yeah
um
someone said Pearl will you be able to
raise your kid with your YouTube
business that way you are home more plus
your dad is right one wife before four
wives
um my plan I cannot when I have kids I
will not do these shows I will not do
these shows when I have children
um that's not really conducive to a
family no
um I don't know when I have um
the business will come second when you
have a family the family comes first so
whatever
's best for the family did you ever get
finessed because I kind of feel like you
run this every girl's like so hard like
everybody's taken else I wouldn't be in
a position to be able to give this
information if I didn't take plenty of
bills listen he's definitely been
finessed before and now he's like come
back with a vengeance okay I'll be I'll
be interesting to see what like your
experience with London women are
okay can I be they're not as hard as the
girls in Miami I'll just be honest
yo I'm sorry London chicks I've said
that I'm a point hotter in London I
don't look it
I'm a solid
I'm a solid five in the United States I
get six to seven six to seven U.S and
it's because London chicks aren't as hot
and if they are they aren't usually from
here I'm sorry London
I'm sorry
um you know but Miami is an anomaly like
we got the most attractive girls you
know per capita like in any some place
in the world like if you compete like
maybe with Colombia Brazil Etc but yeah
I mean Miami is an anomaly yeah British
girls are not as hot as Miami girls I
mean but yeah it is what it is but we'll
see what happens I mean I'll I'll try to
womanize here and see what happens but
my standards oh yeah well Miami yeah
Miami also the girls
you want to be humbled real quick go to
Miami
it's not good that's a good thing see
it's such a Negative term but womanizers
are actually the best guys
yeah womanized I hope he meets a woman
from South really they know what's
attractive they know how to take Raw on
a date they know how to treat a woman
well Etc it's the weirdos that you guys
don't want the womanizer is the ones you
guys want the misogynists those guys I
would argue sexism benefits women
100 why is that because with sexism it
adds a whole other standard and a whole
other league for women I mean if there
was a sexism there wouldn't be a WNBA or
a female MLS or we wouldn't have
different standards I agree look at the
fact that they subsidize women's sports
his sexist and I'm glad it happens I
don't think it's fair
but [ __ ] like that's the only reason I'm
here let's the only reason I've gotten
to play as long as I've had
thanks for keeping it real pearl your
content has helped me steer clear of
plenty of 304s got a few feminine low
body count options now
I'm happy for you bro I'm happy for you
sorry I gotta stop saying bro I'm happy
for you sir
sir
you know female police officers are
female firefighters Etc I mean okay I
don't believe in female police officers
I swear to God especially in the UK if
someone breaks in my apartment and they
send me a woman what the f what is a
woman gonna do an average guy can be
both of us up he's just gonna take your
gun he's just gonna
yeah I don't believe in in the UK if I'm
not mistaken female firefighters can
fail to test and still get the job
versus a man would never be able to do
that I can't think of anything sexist
that benefits men besides maybe being
able to sleep with a lot of girls and
being respected but that's tough to do
this
what else what other double standard
benefits
I can't think of any other one yeah I
can't think of one
as a woman 100 very difficult I do agree
like it's a lot harder for men to get
sex but I kind of I don't understand
like why there's so much obsession with
like this body count and everything and
the double standards do you have an
issue that men have an issue with a
woman's body count or do you have an
issue with men wanting a lot of sex a
bit of both really because I kind of
feel like you get mad okay if a woman is
sleeping with multiple men yeah
rightfully so but then if you do the
same men and women aren't the same what
about this let's see look at it might
not really get mad they don't really get
mad I would say like this men just don't
want to wife you after like I think that
men appreciate hoes this is unpopular
opinion men appreciate hosts they don't
respect them but they appreciate you
they're like yeah I needed
I needed um someone for Tuesdays and
Mondays that's not Main Chick night
clearly my main chick's working on
Mondays and Tuesdays I need a side chick
in your dating right hypothetically and
you find out that I might have done some
gay porn in the past to make some money
what would happen
it'd be over actually I
shouldn't for women
oh my God I have a question what if a
guy did a gay scene
a gay scene
okay wait I'm gonna ask
[Music]
um
who can I call
them Yo what do you guys think someone
will answer
you think someone will answer
[Music]
[Music]
um
I'm gonna just keep playing I don't know
this is gonna be sad what would happen
yeah I feel like you would break up with
me that's the truth you would leave me
if you found out well because I would
assume that you were gay and then I'm
your Secret to cover up your game my
past matters right no but it's not
necessarily like the fact that it's your
past that matters it's just the fact
that you aren't being but it was it was
unattractive that's how men feel and and
you weren't being honest right
how many girls lie about their body
count
women that have a past men are
interested in a woman's past women are
interested in a man's future body count
matters ladies if you're a hoe you are a
hoe by a definition and men are not hoes
we are Homemakers that's the reality so
would you not be with a woman for her
family background or whatever like that
because I kind of for when you do your
background check that those things are
really important when you're dating
someone okay I'd prefer a guy that had
two parents I'm sorry it's like if you
haven't seen what a marriage looks like
how are you gonna do it kind of want to
understand their mindset yeah there's
always exceptions to the rule but in
general
um girls that come from broken homes
typically tend to have very bad habits
girls that don't have a father in their
life typically tend to have bad habits
is this all no but a majority of women
that don't have these things in place
typically don't end up being uh good
women in general they don't have
rudimentary Basics or if they have
trauma in their life whatever you know
trauma destroys women but it builds men
this guy is insane like I actually think
he believes his own [ __ ] so as a guy
it's your job to find a girl that isn't
and it's gonna sound terrible and
hopefully don't get cancer from me
saying it's tarnished tarnished yeah
it's not really if I had to say
tarnished yeah
it's fair but it's true and this is an
unpopular opinion some men can be so
damaged that
it's completely different for men for
women like it affects women worse but my
point is this some men like like it's
not even bad like you could say that
about some men and women wouldn't get
upset like you could say oh he was too
damaged and women wouldn't get upset but
when they say it about vice versa it's
like
because like a lot of people do hold
themselves accountable and do the work
and personal development well yes we do
no no we don't stop it stop it you know
damn well we don't you know damn well we
don't you know
why does he keep laughing at me most
girls don't hold themselves accountable
whatsoever most girls rarely
self-approve if ever most girls think
I'm special I'm perfect the way that I
am I'm a princess I deserve the world
and unfortunately reality kind of smacks
them in the face because they can't keep
a guy long term they just get used for
sex and once modern day women understand
that you actually have to compete you
actually have to show up to that job
interview for that prestigious law firm
in a suit and actually be ready to do
the work you're never going to be able
to keep a job or in this case keep a guy
foreign
have you ever suffered with mental
health no thankfully really if I'm going
through something I'm able to just like
kind of use it as motivation to push
myself through that that time period so
how'd you deal with it through Fitness
I'm guessing yeah that's a big one I was
a division one athlete in college and I
rode it's a very painful sport for
anyone that does it so if you can do a
you know 2000 meter race or a 6 000
meter race then you can deal with a lot
of other stuff you know I will say I
think athletes it act absolutely builds
character and discipline being an
athlete in college men or women like I
just
yeah
yeah makes you mentally tough
do you find that you always have to be
tough yeah you can't afford to not be as
a man because the difference is this
when a woman cries on the man's shoulder
that man doesn't lose attraction and
respect for that woman however if a man
cries on a woman's shoulder she's
inevitably going to lose respect for
that man she might not at that moment
she might be there like I got you
whatever but there's something revolting
from a female perspective to see their
man crying now you might not be someone
that's like that but I've had so many
women on my podcast say I thought I can
accept it but when you cry in front of
me it just changed and and the reason
why is because like there's this
visceral like switch in a woman's head
it's like this guy's crying in front of
me showing weakness damn this guy can't
protect me and provide for me right even
if it's not true even if it's like a
moment of weakness it can show something
that like oh this guy isn't there
because like women are designed to look
look and that's true like
this is why women give a horrible advice
to men and I'm sure I probably have said
this at some point on some of my
reactions but we this is what we don't
understand like first first you
you think like oh yeah they could cry
but it's like if they do that often you
will leave and you're not gonna be
attracted to his ass and it's not saying
like
never
but like no girl wants a guy that's
crying all the time and you know it
survival value in men men are designed
to look for replication value women yeah
I think it's like I think it's unfair to
like completely rule that out because I
feel like it's fair for a man to be able
to do that you are allowed to have him
and this is okay unpopular opinion this
is one of the traits that I think men
Overlook in women now
just personal opinion okay this isn't
I'm probably biased because I'm a woman
but I also look at the women that my
brothers chose that I really like
now
I think that men Overlook work ethic
from women because here's the thing like
you don't want a girl that's like lazy
and sitting around the house all the
time you don't want that if you're going
to train a girl she's got to work hard
to be trained being a molding yourself
to a man isn't easy it's not easy if you
want a girl that works hard to like
learn to cook learn to like whatever it
is work ethics important and but men
aren't attracted to it like women are
attracted to that men don't really care
like it's just kind of there but I feel
like that's one of the things that men
Overlook in women because I'll see it
all the time where it's like
a guy will date a girl but she's lazy
and she's like pretty and she's fun but
she's lazy so long term
you know she just like doesn't do
anything and then he's like working I'm
cleaning around the house she's not
helping him in any way you know just
personal opinion but you can take that
or leave it it's a fair thought okay
life's not fair but I think you should
be allowed your moment of weakness and I
kind of feel like from a woman's
perspective it would be then how you
then deal with that I think you should
end world hunger I also think that we
shouldn't have nuclear weapons people
shouldn't be dying needlessly Etc but I
can't operate and should have couldn't
would I operate on what is and what is
is that women I talk about this I don't
tell the world what to be it just is
what it is I don't I don't want guys to
have four wives but [ __ ]
there's a dude in Africa I guess I had
like over a hundred wives like over 200
that's crazy
apparently unattracted to weak men and
crying and showing vulnerability is a
component to that no so you wouldn't cry
in front of me absolutely not never you
would never see that
have you ever been in love
to a woman
yeah
I've had love for women but I don't
think yeah I don't think it's a man in a
man's best interest to be in love with a
woman but if you lose control so I feel
like
um everything and your standpoint on
women is going to change the moment you
like meet the right woman
yeah that's cute but no I mean I I have
I've had love for women but I'm never
going to fall in love with a woman
because when you fall in love with a
woman what happens is you start to lose
grounding and you start to lose that
rational thought a lot of the stupid
things that men do is because of love so
you're scared to be vulnerable no and
let yourself go and be in love like
you're gonna block yourself
from like emotion and to fill for
something that could be really amazing
for you because you're scared to be
vulnerable no because I understand that
men and women are different and Men love
women far differently than women I do
think it's better when the woman loves
the man whether the man loves the woman
my mom would say the opposite she would
say it should be the other way around
but she's a woman we don't even know
what we want
men love women for real women love men
women love men for real no they don't
women love men under the premise that
they provide value men love women
idealistically women tend to love men
more from an opportunistic standpoint
yes you don't no I've got all my can I
just say all men say they don't and they
actually do I really don't you've never
done it in your life no I've done in my
life so yes but the last time I did it
was 2014. I remember specifically once
yeah never again
[Music]
female vaginas are disgusting no they're
not do you eat vagina
exactly Point prove it
no point proven you don't do it why
should I do it listen a woman's body is
beautiful she was bi
if you're bi you don't however you buy
if you don't
okay what I don't understand is like why
it's such a Stern though because why
wouldn't you want to please
your woman you know because have you not
ever like I said before it's a woman's
job to please a man out the other way
around no that is actually ridiculous
when it comes to being intimate and in
the bedroom
it's not it's like when Once when you do
something for someone have you not seen
how and they like it have you not seen
how much they perform better and I'm not
just talking sexually like in general I
don't like an [ __ ] but a woman's
ejaculation is irrelevant
you only need one ejaculation to create
life and that's demands now with that
said does that mean I'm not going to
please my girl or whatever of course I
will but it's elective definition in bed
just like a woman's you know duty to go
to work is elective my duty to please
her sexually is elective that's
ridiculous how's everything because oh
no oh you know how about this with that
logic I'm gonna stop paying the bills
that would be ridiculous
huh I'll have to go and work better stop
paying the bills yeah we did and then
you lose attraction for me wouldn't you
[Music]
but I just don't understand why like
just I feel if you just started doing it
you might have a bit of like
relationship well no I women might not
your woman might not like it but I'm
just saying from a sample I don't
understand why you have to constantly
dominate even in this scenario like
having sex is an intimate thing it's an
energy exchange energy Exchange
more typical female gibberish like bro
energy exchange what the hell bro get
out of here with that oh my God I hate
it when girls say that too they say it
all the time on the podcast we exchange
energies and I'm like
I I understand what they're saying a
little bit from like a woman's point of
view
but men don't see it that way we we give
them something
they take it they ain't giving us [ __ ] I
don't know how this [ __ ] works but yeah
yeah really beautiful thing so why would
you not want to make her feel good most
women get off on you getting off that's
the truth
[Music]
if we're going to be all the way about
this no no no no women thought that no
no women used to think that through porn
really everything like yeah yeah okay
but and this is what I'm saying but
women have started Persian ourselves
doing things and now we know how nice
certain things feel women are more
miserable now than ever before I don't
even know that's true that's true
there's more women at antidepressants so
you can't you can't really argue women
derive their pleasure from serving a man
they love in my respect and their
children I provide
so then you got to provide the
ejaculations
I mean I don't know what's so hard to to
get about
I mean yeah that's true I mean like a
man if a man's marrying you or with you
a long time you should give him sex I
just yeah I don't know why you would
fight that cat if you've been serious or
you're actually like I think you can
kind of build a bond with a woman
through other stuff but you know
I don't really care people can do what
they want there's a guy getting his girl
off is elective let me see Candace
bushel is one of the producers of Sex in
the City and regrets choosing her career
life instead of a family because now
she's 60 and alone
Pearl you're great but is there anything
you disagree with Myron on
I'm gonna just keep going do it but they
don't have to just like I think a man
has to work in his woman okay we'll just
do it and then just see what you get
different results that's what I'm saying
I don't do that I'm not and if that and
if that's what she like needs to get off
well too bad not doing it wow yeah
because that's a submissive thing too
that like I'm not what is your issue
with men submitting to women like
genuine girl you know we don't want a
man that submits to us that's like the
first way to get us to leave this is a
big issue of yours oh really okay yeah
so what I'm saying but I'm just saying
don't go into don't don't worry don't go
into it because you're about to go into
it I'm just saying genuinely you have
such an issue with just you don't like
when I use your logic on you he has
definitely got some issues no I just
don't like the fact that you it's this
power of dominating thing that you want
as a man like yes you can have it but
just in some situations just know when
to also submit as a man and surrender
not everyday masculine man
I'm glad you find it funny absolutely
not we will not cons we don't negotiate
with terrorists
[Laughter]
have been dogs
that women were reasonable
until I did my podcast I don't anymore I
won't lie to you guys I'm just being
honest
some luminar but by and large we are not
terrorists what's them the relationship
like with the women in your life like
family-wise fantastic it's actually my
mom that taught me a lot of the I grew
up in a Muslim household so she was the
one that told me don't commit to these
Western women blah blah
um so my mom is actually like a very
strong
um symbol in my life when it comes to
navigating uh this situation if it
weren't for her I'd probably be a simp
you know really um yeah I mean I grew up
in a but my parents were together to
this day my man my my dad my dad was the
man my mom was the woman my dad LED my
mom followed and you know they they have
a fantastic relationship and a big part
of that is because they they you know
stuck to their roles and it was my mom
that told me from a young age don't
don't marry these Americans I want to be
that mother
these women ain't [ __ ] son these women
ain't [ __ ] like you can't trust them
she said she was a vert okay okay I'm in
these Western women they're not gonna
cook and clean for you they're not gonna
um they're not gonna take care of you
you're gonna come to the home it's gonna
be the shovel blah blah blah I used to
think to myself like Mom chill what's
wrong with you but as now that I'm 32
versus being 12 20 years later I'm able
to look back on that advice and be like
God damn mom would spend some heat back
in the day yeah it makes sense yeah so
it's understandable why it's like you
think the way that you think because of
your environment and your influence
which is which is a good thing for you
my my background right like I didn't
like at first it was like okay I don't
agree with this right because I used to
be like you know growing a grown-up
American I was born in Connecticut I was
like Mom you're wrong like women aren't
like that what's wrong with you blah
blah blah like you're you're a
misogynist mom and you've got some
ingrained massage me right you even said
that no no no but like I I back then I
don't even think I knew what that word
was uh that's like a buzz term nowadays
that no one knows the definition of
anyway but anyway
um
so as I got older right like the things
that she started to say started to
reflect more and more when I dealt with
more and more girls and I was like what
the hell is going on here and talking
with other men talking with you know
with women Etc my experiences like and
then talking with thousands of men and
then also talking about I'm in a very
unique position where I've talked to
both both genders on on a podcast
coaching sessions Etc so I'm gonna you
know very certain situation where I'm
able to get anecdotal evidence I have
statistics Etc to back up what I'm
saying and I would say my approach to
dealing with women dating relationship
sex Etc is a very pragmatic way to
approach the dating Marketplace based on
today's scenarios with this dating
advice working in 1950s maybe not
because women were different back then
but nowadays do you think I know don't
think women were different that's what I
was thinking I think women just had less
opportunity and more consequences back
then but I think women have always been
hypergamous I was at this Art Museum and
there were some women that were like
leaving their families and they got
stoned to death in like the description
I'm like I think women have always been
like this
hmm
it says no one dates Pro unless Auntie
Jenny bets them oh yeah Auntie Jenny's
sending me on dates
um and T Jenny you can put your
Instagram in the description or whatever
but yeah basically
Auntie Jenny has going to vet
guys and send me on dates with them so
yeah also I started my I started my
cookbook today just so you know with
Auntie Jenny they're Signet they're
significantly different like from a more
negative standpoint not to a man's
benefit
over okay nice yes it's a hell no
unacceptable disgusting hurray I've
never wiped that girl up recreational
use only 30 is a lot
that's a lot 30 is a lot
why a hell no
it was yours what's my body count
what's the uh the term in England when
you don't want to when you want to
invoke the Fifth Amendment but you can't
no comment no comment there we go no
comments sir
is yours over 200
300
yours is a lot more Sparta wow and you
wanna it's yours is over 300 and you
want to get mad at 30. this this isn't
even a double standard anymore like he's
just taking it too far I think it's more
attractive if a man doesn't because if
you can no it is like if you can show
discipline why are you laughing yeah no
because if for me it shows like
self-control and discipline it's because
when we say that we just mean we don't
want a guy that slept with a bunch of
people we know that's what we mean
because that's like embarrassing it's
like ah he had yeah
I've left to their own devices want to
have sex with as many women as possible
men are designed to spread seed we want
quantity women are designed to protect
their egg for the best seed women want
quality we're very different
yeah
do you think you're liked as a person
that's a good question that's a very
very good question
and my thing is create a legacy so that
whether they like you or not they
respect you
that's what I care about I don't care if
people like me or not because I'll tell
you this there's plenty of girls that
I've had sex with that didn't like me
but they respected me
because women must respect you to [ __ ]
you yeah
yes I know so why wouldn't you
I wanted to say because I'm the man you
were attracted to me in the first place
because of my lifestyle I'm not going to
change who I am because of a woman
when a man changes for a woman he grows
into something she's going to have
consent for when a woman changes for a
man she'll grow into something he'll
love that's how I got you in the first
place why would I change and that's the
biggest mistake that guys make is they
get in a relationship they get
accomplished that's true that's true
they get fat they get less ambitious
because they're like oh I got the woman
I should be comfortable nah she might
leave your ass
she might leave your ass be careful they
lose their ambition our daughter yeah
blah blah blah and that woman starts to
lose what respect for him
when a woman changes for a man he gains
more respect for her men and women are
so different aren't they yeah when
you're changing for a woman that
inevitably puts her in her leadership
role and when the woman's in the
leadership role she's gonna lead you all
right to them the relationship
that was funny
do you give your partner your phone
password no what I wouldn't mind I
wouldn't really care
oh I'm not gonna let a girl look at my
phone why because I'm gonna have other
girls I'd like to keep my
I know everyone's gonna be like girls
keep the wildest [ __ ]
sometimes I write song lyrics and my
notes app
some of them are embarrassing I'd just
rather
I'd just rather eat
I might move to a notebook like an
action you know I would not be right
I'll be writing like bars you know
freestyles
I don't want anyone looking at that okay
I don't I don't want anyone nobody
that's the only thing that I would
rather not share
100 the thing is is that most of them
can handle the truth so I'm gonna be I'm
very big on like being upfront and
letting her know listen I'm gonna have
other girls whatever it may be but
you're the main one and she's got to
accept that but her looking at my phone
is just gonna hurt her feelings so you
want an open relationship yeah open her
mind close on her own okay what would be
more offensive if you look through his
phone and saw that he had sex with
another girl or you looked at his phone
and you saw that he tried and she denied
him that's not fair though life isn't
fair I don't know I just kind of feel
like the kind of relationship that I
want
isn't that what if I told you women
don't know what they want in general
sometimes most don't some this has been
statistically proven that women don't
know what they want cool and yeah
they're all in cell culture podcast okay
women don't know what they want and
worse yet they're not going to be honest
about what they want because of strict
societal standards where they don't want
to look like hoes yeah because you guys
call women hoes rightfully so not right
you have to
you have to describe it like what else
are you going to describe
foreign
just like be sexually liberated
genuinely why does she have to be a hoe
okay do you want to be a hoe I don't
really care what you think if you're
going to say I'm home I'm saying no I'm
asking no girl wants to be a hoe
language should be real
I don't really I'm not attacking you I'm
asking you this as a question I don't
want to be labeled a hoe for what you
guys paint as at home well let's peel
the layer back do you want to go out and
have sex with a bunch of different men
at the same time why would I want to do
that okay
you want to hear something magical most
women don't want to do that most girls
don't even want to be hoes yet girls
argue and you know debate to be hoes I
don't get it they don't want to be host
we don't but it's just kind of it's just
a double standard we don't want you to
where where sorry why are we going to
cry like I mean there's a bunch of
double standards that don't benefit I'm
just saying that I feel like there's
hyper-independence Liberation like
movement is because we're just sick of
men like you that want to just attack
women for being able to do something
that you guys are doing just as much not
attacking but I'm saying in general like
I'm reporting a fact if a woman is
promiscuous she is by definition to help
around you sleeping around I am a
homemaker
a homemaker
you're just an idiot men can't be hoes
okay men yeah it's true it's true look
it um
it's true that have sex a lot of women
are successful in your eyes as men this
is the thing it's like this Brotherhood
thing it's you guys it's you okay okay
let's go back actually I want to see if
we got this one person to come on our
show
uh
what did her team say
I want to see if
and no no we're not going to keep going
back to biology actually that's where I
always come from why does he keep going
back to biology we're not in a science
lesson
because it
match Diane she's a perfectly nice lady
but it matters it matters
so what would you do if I was going on
holiday every other month
you'd be single ready are we going
together are you going by yourself I
just feel like
where I'd wanna I mean I don't hang out
with girls like
but I don't
I just feel like I'd rather travel with
a guy than not
I'm on vacations with my family
but like you can come you know what I
mean oh no you'd be single what would
you do if I couldn't cook you'd be
single
can you cook
that's irrelevant no can you cook though
I mean can you fight
that's exactly the last pointless
questions how's that pointless question
you kind of get to know you because
that's your job what's my job to make
sandwiches did he actually just say my
job is to make sandwiches how am I going
to fight off The Intruders if you don't
make sandwiches I need sustenance
you're a dick what would you do if I
earned my money
it would never happen how'd you know
that
because no girl is going to match my
ambition or drive I'm quite an ambitious
woman LOL that's cute but it would never
happen men build a world for real like
why why is the goal always about like
being on top
firstly well missionaries are fantastic
position first of all and the other
reason why men have to be on top is
because that's the only thing women
respect there's so many people that just
like a nice quiet humble life here's the
thing all women you know what stop
saying over in as well okay now that
you've said that all women want a guy
that's better than them why'd you get
annoyed and so frustrated about men that
are simps they're giving women that
don't deserve attention and validation
attention and validation they're messing
up for everybody it's nice when you have
men that are attentive to your needs by
you being successful yeah but let's be
honest we always like the ones that
don't like us why is that
why is that being the man that she wants
in general you're already attentive to
her needs what would you do if your
family didn't like me too bad I've made
you know
Ultra
my parents trust my judgment and they
would accept it what would you do if I
respect that answer I feel like
your parents can't can only influence
you so so much but it's kind of like if
you pick someone you picked them
a lot of male friends a girl that has a
lot of guy friends is a problem that's a
liability male friends big red flag if a
girl has a bunch of male friends and
she's not willing to give that up to be
with you for the streets women value a
man that has social proof men don't care
about a woman social proof when you have
friends it's a liability when I have
friends it's social proof it makes me
more attractive it makes you less
attractive what would you do if your
friends were liking my pictures I don't
associate with men that can't attract
women all my friends are good with women
there's a bunch of reasons for this but
you can't hang out with simps you can't
have friends that are thirsty for women
yeah Sims mess everything up but makes
it better for guys like us man we just
come in and
it is what it is we clean up anytime a
woman is the focal of a man's life it's
a problem
100 percent
and the only way a man can give a woman
the best life is when she's not the
focus I don't think so
well that's easy for you to say as woman
what would you do if I wanted to start
an only fence
you're serious yeah
yeah you'd be single why'd every single
because I'm not going to have my girl
out there on the internet showing her
butthole for 3.99 your girl wants to do
only fence bro you ain't got a girl you
got a 304. to the street she shall
return I'm telling you or else your life
is gonna suck but what if I just wanted
to make my own money can't do it uh okay
men go to McDonald's and get a job stop
it stop it go go get a job go get a job
I'm so tired of this narrative this
narrative oh as a woman I had no choice
I was a single mother what about the
single fathers they don't do this
it's like oh I was a single father so I
dealt drugs
of your assistant an actual paid
assistant yeah yeah paid by promise
you're getting everything else you get
the lifestyle you're living for free
traveling the world whatever it may be
you get the title of my last name it's a
W for you all the way you get seen in
public with me here's ego
is through the roof
I will say you can tell
Andrew Tate just has a lot more like
game than my like you can just tell
how do you think you're done on the day
this was supposed to be a date yes would
you like me to be more submissive oh my
God hey would that would that make you
feel better it would but it's okay it
was a debate it's fine really so next
time if if you want to date a debate
date so everybody wants to date you she
just has to come then to pick me I mean
giving a man what he wants there's
nothing wrong with that no of course not
yeah
well that's like pretty much it
yeah
um I liked the video I thought that was
funny
um
let's see
yeah
I'm just reading the chat damn
she's for the streets future
um
well that's my reaction for now guys I
think we're gonna have a show tonight
we've had we're supposed to be out of
town
I don't know we'll see we'll see we
might have a show tonight I'll let you
guys know
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next